hi my name is Adam Carrington and I'm an
assistant professor of politics here at
Hillsdale College and I'd like to ask
the question can the police arrest you
for speaking freely for exercising your
right to free speech that question
actually came up in the court this week
in avis versus Bartlett Bartlett was
attending a function called Arctic man
up in Alaska and got into an altercation
with with several Alaskan police
officers they arrested him he argues
that they did so to retaliate against
certain things he said and refused to
say to them and so the question the
court had to take up is a balance of two
principles on one hand we can't have the
government arresting you to retaliate
for things you believe and things that
you've expressed for example what if you
believe something about abortion or
immigration or local zoning ordinances
that police don't agree with can they
arrest you and the answer is no but on
the other side police have to make often
snap judgments to protect us and if we
were to not allow them some discretion
in arresting or not arresting persons we
would have very little law enforcement
and therefore very little protection of
our life liberty and property given that
how is the court to balance the two I
think the majority while getting the
vote right voting with the officers that
they were allowed to do what they did
still got the principle a little bit off
on one hand they gave a blanket
protection to the police if the police
could show that they had probable cause
for the arrest now I think probable
cause should play a role I think some of
the other opinions some of the
concurrences particularly by Gorsuch and
Ruth Bader Ginsburg pointed out that
this shouldn't be a blanket protection
instead probable call should be one
factor to show that police were not
arresting you because they didn't like
what you said and in doing so what
someone like Gorsuch in particular
recognizes is that free speech rights
aren't the same as Fourth Amendment
rights
amendment rights protect you against
being arrested for no reason but you can
be arrested for a decent reason and
arrested because your speaking things
the government doesn't want you to say
Gorsuch is opinion and I would say
Ginsburg's as well sets up a more
nuanced standard that allows protection
to police officers so that they can
carry out their job but at the same time
gives protection to free speech rights
as free speech rights for the protection
of our Liberty in general